in this lesson we're going to talk about
permutations combinations and factorials
so let's go over some definitions here
first and then we'll get into the
examples so when you see this
n factorial this exclamation point
that's a factorial what it means is you
take that quantity that n and then you
multiply by the number that's one less
and then one less than that all the way
down until you get to one so for example
if you have five factorial that's going
to be five times four times three times
two times one you would multiply all
those together
now with permutations and combinations
what you want to pay attention to is
whether the order is important or the
other order is not important so for
example if you pick two things out of a
hat and if you pick a first and then b
or b first and then a if the order is
important
then you want to use the permutation
formula if the order doesn't matter then
you want to use the combination formula
and basically what these formulas tell
us are
that out of n objects how many ways are
there to pick
groups of r so for example there's 10
objects how many ways are there to pick
two of them where the order matters or
out of 10 of them how do we how many
ways are there to choose two of them
where the order really doesn't matter so
a and b b and a that would be considered
two different outcomes for permutations
but just one outcome that's the same
outcome for combinations so here's the
formula here n factorial over n minus r
factorial here the combination one is
almost exactly the same except for you
can see we're dividing by another r
factorial because we're dividing out the
multiplicity so you know a and b being a
that's the same thing we're dividing out
those duplicates so hopefully you
covered this a little bit in your math
class but just a quick review here let's
do some examples to clear it up a little
bit further
see if you can do these on your own
pause the video and then we can go
through them together but example one
says how many distinct permutations okay
that means orderings right are there of
the letters in the word college okay so
the first thing we want to look at is
okay here's college so college is
basically one two three four five six
seven letters
well there's going to be seven factorial
ways of ordering
seven letters right because you could
have you know seven choices for what
letter you put in the first position and
then there would be six left for which
uh to choose for the second position all
the way down to one for the last
position so that's seven factorial but
we have a little uh hitch here in the
sense that there's two l's and there's
two e's so whether you put these l's
like this or like this same thing with
the e's if you interchange your
positions it's not going to look like a
different word so what we have to do is
we have to divide out those
duplicates now if there was three l's
we'd be dividing out three factorial if
there was you know five e's we'd be
dividing out five factorial so if we
simplify this down we get uh seven
factorial which is seven six five four
three two one over two factorial which
is two times one which is two and two
times one again which is two so that's
four
and we have seven factorial divided by
four
and you can simplify from there
so for example two it says how many ways
are there to pick two co-captains
for a swim team consisting of 25
swimmers now let me ask you a question
does the order matter
not really it's not like one's like the
president and one's the vice president
you know they're on the same level
they're co-captains so in this case
we're going to use the combinations and
we're going to be using
25
choose 2. so out of 25 swimmers how many
ways are there to choose 2 where the
order doesn't matter so if we simplify
this we get 25 factorial
over 25 minus 2 which is 23 factorial
2 factorial now if you want to simplify
further 25 factorial is 25 times 24
times 23 all the way down to 1. 23
factorial is 23 times 22 all the way
down to one and you can see these are
cancelling so you just have 25 times 24
all divided by 2 times 1 which is 2
and then you know you can simplify it
from there
okay now example 3 it says how many ways
are there to order five dvds on a
bookshelf
okay this one's pretty straightforward
it's just going to be five factorial
which is five times four times three
times two times one which is a hundred
and twenty different ways and you could
diagram it out like this
there's five choices for which dvd you
put here and then now there's only four
degrees left to pick for the second
position all the way down to one
multiply those together and you get 120.
so a review here of permutations
combinations and factorials
you might want to memorize those
formulas so it makes it a little bit
easier when you're when you see these
types of problems on the test